台灣股市今天又上漲了538點
要突破歷史新高了
轉眼間48000了
要48000了
轉眼間要50000了
我要告訴你
今天有一件事情
要讓台灣股市有機會上50000
什麼事情
來 我先講今天三大重點
台股連4紅了
剩500點創新高 怎麼看
真的會創新高嗎
第二個 我的0050大賺快2000萬了
大概1987萬
要出了嗎
第三個 伊朗放寬和談條件
停戰有譜
你有沒有發現到
我每天跟你講心靈故事 心靈雞湯
要等待 噴出去了
當然你現在也可以找麻煩說
哲哲 這是你賺錢
你不要這樣講
很多人也是跟著我買台灣50
現在輪到台灣50
前陣子輪到00981A
是不是漲了快30%
現在是台灣50在漲 台積電在漲
然後非台積電的像垃圾一樣
沒有關係 等一段時間你就知道
真正恐怖的是那些中小型個股
是那些被動元件
還有什麼 還有矽晶圓
講到矽晶圓那個定價
GDR定價要出來了
等一下再跟大家講 來
大家好 我是摩爾投顧投資長
也是全台灣唯一百萬粉絲訂閱
不只 140萬粉絲訂閱的分析師
你沒有聽過哲哲
你一定是股市菜鳥中的菜鳥
一定是 全台灣誰沒聽過哲哲的
先跟大家講
這個自我介紹這樣就夠了 來
那我們來看一下
大盤的行情是這樣子 來
你看一下
你看 有一位分析師在這邊買進
漂亮嗎 有沒有
黃仁勳喜歡說台語
漂亮嗎 這裡買啦放大啦
這裡啦 漲到這裡啦
沒關係 放大就好
這裡啦 我在這邊買啦
我不只在這邊買
在這邊 最低點這一天
隔天你還可以買到相對低點
這邊買啦
漲到這裡啦
39384點這一天啦
現在已經8000點了啦
8000點 八千里路雲和月
這個老節目了
8000點 扒來扒去
Blah-blah i'm lovin' it
你有沒有搞錯 各位
當初我是這樣講
我跟你講50000點
你告訴我哪個分析師
敢跟你講說50000點
有啦 在這邊的時候
一堆分析師跟你講50000點
在這邊48000的時候
這邊沒有一位敢跟你講50000點
誰 Tell me
就如同去年年底的時候26000而已
有誰跟你講36000
有誰跟你講40000
只有我而已
你不選最紅的選誰
像我知道有些股票
今天有點開高走低
我不在乎 上50000點都一樣
通通都是一樣
所以你去想想看你要怎樣的分析師
來 我們看一下
大家互動
沒有互動的話 我跟你說真的
第一個 我有兩種方式
一種是我直接就隱藏
影片隱藏起來
花錢訂閱 一個月花個100塊
我100塊或500塊
我跟你講 我這樣光一個月
我就可以多個
因為我的影片大概10幾 20萬人看
我一個月收入
可以多個500萬到1000萬
我沒跟你開玩笑
一定很多人訂
就算少一半人也沒關係 還是划算
第二種 就是我不直播
這不直播是最有可能
因為直播我的臉的色彩沒那麼好
因為我最近看了韓劇以後
發現有些韓劇好帥好美
後來看他本人沒那麼帥
發現那個燈光打的有差 後製有差
所以我很不想直播
因為直播的話很難調燈光
都把我心裡話跟大家講
要記得按讚
直播還不給我按讚
懂不懂 OK
川普不忍了
嗆聲要完全摧毀伊朗
這什麼時候的新聞
助理幫我查一下
不會啦 我要告訴你啦
我剛剛不是講第三件事情嗎
伊朗放寬和談條件 停戰有譜
伊朗放越大聲
越有機會和談 為什麼
我跟你講啦
伊朗也不是傻瓜啦
你現在不和談
等選舉過後再和談 穩死的啦
川普現在的軟肋就是期中選舉
你不敢快趁9月的時候 10月的時候
跟川普和談
我跟你講 慘了
而且我告訴你 伊朗有和談
我告訴你喔
我今天不是說什麼
這件事讓台灣股市上50000萬嗎
我直接告訴你
就是伊朗要放寬和談
來 全台灣應該只有我寫這麼清楚
來 看一下
我是伊朗分析師
也是被動元件專家
也是記憶體跟矽晶圓專家
好 來 叫我記憶體王子
伊朗停戰條件有沒有看到
4月的時候有沒有看到
美國保證不再侵略伊朗
這都是伊朗的要求
聽得懂嗎
美國怎麼可能會這樣做
你覺得美國不再保證侵略伊朗有可能嗎
怎麼可能
你如果伊朗做壞事怎麼可能
如果美國認同他做壞事
他現在只有要求
停止對伊朗的領土攻擊
伊朗4月跟現在的要求不一樣
一個是不再侵略
哪有可能啊
叫我不再打你怎麼可能
可是你說停止這一次有機會
所以9月這個比較務實
第二個 4月十點是和談過後
伊朗還是要掌控海峽
現在不講了
現在不講說我要一輩子掌控了
我要重開海峽
其實現在伊朗經濟也受不了
因為高通膨
他們以前引以為傲是可以賣原油
現在是封鎖荷姆茲海峽
伊朗也封鎖他的荷姆茲海峽
就大家都不要送出去
誰比較痛苦
當然是伊朗比較痛苦
你知道伊朗最近有一個事件
一開飛機那個天花板就爆了
一坐飛機 民航機 為什麼
因為現在連伊朗的飛機對不對
零組件要維修對不對
不好意思 不讓你維修了
美國人不讓他送過去
你聽得懂嗎
所以伊朗一定越來越多抗議
所以這個受不了
解除所有主要制裁有沒有看到
他沒有
他只有說解凍資金 這個還好
未重提全面解除制裁
這個還好嘛 就回到戰前
美軍撤出區域
有說要解
美軍撤出區域怎麼可能
我在那個伊朗對面
那個沙烏地阿拉伯 沙特
沙烏地阿拉伯大公國
我在那邊有空軍基地
我怎麼可能會撤掉
撤掉川普不用選了啦
以後共和黨不用選了
所以以前要求的條件都是不合邏輯的
伊朗4月要求的條件
都是不可能達成的
現在 來注意聽清楚
現在伊朗所要求的條件
通通是有機會達成的
所以我直接跟你講了啦
來 倒數計時
一個月內美伊會和談成功
你喜歡看我的節目
就是喜歡看我預告未來啦
是不是 現在很多人
很多醫生 很多院長講
AI告訴你
很多人 藥學 醫藥
一年以後
以後製藥幾個月就可以生產一個藥
這個我都跟你講啦
我說90度成長
我跟你講說AI會再發明AI
你都不相信
現在已經考慮AI毀滅人類了
是不是代表發明得很快
我也早就跟你講
什麼變不變現沒問題啊
你就不相信
大摩最近報告告訴你
明年14大CSP 怎麼樣
資本支出要翻一倍
廢話 都已經可以很多賺錢了
所以我就告訴你
我是喜歡當預言家
很多最後分析師在講
看那種過去的財報要幹什麼
最Low
不是說會計師不好
這是兩回事喔
我說你只看過去的財報幹嘛
最Low
你只看現在營收幹嘛 不用
你只要看未來趨勢就好了
來 我直接給你結論
現在伊朗談判的東西要求非常合理
非常合理
美國絕對可以達到 只要他想
知道嗎 只要川普想
川普想不想 當然想啊
所以一個月內
為什麼一個月內
11月期中選舉
你11月再簽約有什麼用
對不起 講話怎麼這麼粗俗
打自己一下
真的打自己一下
對不起 講話太粗俗
11月
有時候太激動你知道嗎
有時候我感覺像演員一樣
明明我是分析師
11月期中選舉才和談沒有用了
那個石油不會下來那麼快
原油期貨會下來那麼快
但是物價不會那麼快
所以我告訴你
美伊和談過後
那就不會升息了
12月升息機率就會下滑
12月升息機率一下滑
股市要噴出去了
所以這件事要讓台灣股市上50000點
好不好 我跟大家講
這就是我籌備很久的
年底上50000點
一切都在我的計畫內
沒關係 接下來重播我再講一次喔
今天幾月幾號 9月21
在一個月內美伊會和談
是正式的和談喔
你們看得清楚原油價格下滑喔
來 那個
助理幫我查一下原油價格
你們幫我查一下原油價格
今天幫我查一個
隨便最新的原油價格
你要講清楚哪邊的原油價格 導播
一個月內和談
升息機率會大降
記得我說這些話 好不好
現在12月升息機率很高嘛
8成以上 會大降
因為這一次談判完全可以
之前叫美軍要撤出區域
我怎麼可能撤出中東基地啊
現在沒有要叫我撤軍啊
只要解除海上封鎖 沒問題啊
之前說就算我和解了
我還是要掌控海峽
現在沒有說
說重開海峽
就模糊不清嘛
那就有機會嘛
所有戰線停戰 包括黎巴嫩
這對美國來講不難啦
我停戰就停戰
好 那你看喔
之前4月有沒有到
承認伊朗濃縮鈾的權利
我承認 川普不是打臉
那是政治自殺
怎麼可能會做這件事
本次都沒有提 好不好
助理直接寫本次未提就好了
下次再幫我重作
解除所有次級制裁
這個也是本次未提到
好不好 OK嗎
所以說我也不一定要全部制裁啦
你先把錢給我啦
終止安理會對伊朗的相關決議
這個美國勉強可以做到
但是這次沒有要求
終止IAEA理事會對伊朗相關決議
這個也沒有重提
好不好 就有關核武這些相關的
賠償伊朗戰爭損失
之前川普是有點願意賠喔
從那個荷姆茲海峽來講喔
從荷姆茲海峽裡面收錢喔
川普是有提到這些東西喔
他是有點願意賠錢喔
他們兩個一起共管嘛
一起管荷姆茲海峽
這一次都沒有提
所以有好幾件事情怎麼樣
Understand
所以這一次就談判要成功了
這件事情4月的時候都有提
現在都沒有提 我再講一次
你聽不懂沒關係
一個月內談判成功 甚至可能更快
原油價格大幅下滑
好不好 我預告了
你趕快買喔
好不好 你趕快買
任何協議要簽訂才算 包含停戰
我認為就是會簽協議
你不要擔心
會簽一個至少很確定的協議
而這個協議是真的會執行
我這樣講好了啦
我覺得我也不確定
就是我也不要跟你講
就是你會看到荷姆茲海峽
真的正常通行
就在10月底之前
好不好 OK嗎
就在10月底之前好不好
包含荷姆茲海峽
就這樣吧
荷姆茲海峽可以正常通行 OK
最長下影線理論
我那時候有說下影線 什麼強
我想很多梗 什麼結算見轉折有沒有
結算見轉折是不是 你看
是不是結算後
禮拜三 禮拜四 禮拜五結算日
禮拜三 禮拜四 禮拜五
到今天47000
這邊45500而已
又漲2000點了
上禮拜45500
今天47750
還會更高
因為我賺了快200萬
1987萬 如果沒記錯的話
還會再漲
10月底之前
一個月內就談好協議了
你就看到荷姆茲海峽通行了
記得一件事好不好
鴻海被遺忘了
鴻海什麼時候睡醒 睡太久
沒關係 到時候都會噴出去好不好
德淵 你不要那邊給我洗版
那是冷門股票
我跟你講 以前有些老投顧
現在還是有些分析師
給你買很冷門的股票
會員全部重壓
你怎麼知道老師有沒有偷買
他可能用人頭戶
我是全台灣唯一認可的
我沒有用人頭戶
也不會私下買 也沒有用個人戶
我再跟你講一件事
這是法院認定的
你不要跟我講那些小型股
我不屑買
我隨便買個小型股
我都可以拉到漲停板
拉了以後那怎麼出 你聽得懂嗎
來看一下
台北地檢署的函 有沒有看到
針對摩爾投顧還有我的
有沒有看到
摩爾公司有沒有看到
摩爾公司對不對
合法投顧公司有沒有看到
查無明顯炒股情事
有沒有看到
沒有故意影響股價或出貨
多次對比相關資料
函請相關單位
函請證交所 偵緝大隊
清清白白
那些同業要搞我 不好意思
投資的誠信你去問
我可以寧可少賺
我光是1.74億的美債 少賺多少
少賺2億
沒有誇張 你去問一下 去算一下
去年到現在
那時候台灣股市多少點
不到20000點
人在做天在看
我不會講那種很小型股票
不夠我塞牙縫
你們要去找那小型股的老師
去找 好不好
摩爾的老師
當然每個人買個股票不一定一樣
但是
就是買小型股的老師不一定做壞事
但是買大型股的老師
絕對不會刻意去做壞事
我的股票就是基本上有價有量
厲害的老師
聯發科要1000多塊跟你講
現在5000塊
我有沒有說這次漲真的
我有買 拉回
有人說哲哲怎麼會變出來漲停板
笑死人
我跟你講一件事
我有這麼多會員能造假嗎
我要是
網路上對我的批評很多
從來沒有一個人敢指名道姓
然後列出來名字說郭哲榮造假
我從不做這種事的 來
拉回這邊你也可以買
噴出去了
現在5000塊了 5010
5010是不是
4000塊的時候你4400趕快買
這個漲停板
我有沒有說過
我說輝達敢買
那你就應該跟輝達一起買
有沒有講
有講就噴出去了
買得漂亮
你們自己不理我 好不好
那這個是特Call會員
因為是高價股買的
我特Call會員也很多人
也是很多人好不好
因禍得福 法院來認證
真的 好不好
一般老師 我怕有些人查一查
我覺得台灣至少有可能十幾位會中箭
真的 我跟你說真的 來
拉回
聯發科拉回有買 OK
環球晶要動了
環球晶應該這一兩天
環球晶這禮拜動的機率很高
但是我不要再亂預告
上次給你預告那個國巨
結果人家說哲哲 怎麼沒漲停
沒辦法 就像我也沒想過
台灣50最近漲的居然比國巨快
我真的沒想過
所以有時候幸福是等來的
幸福是等來的你知道嗎
真的很扯
幸福等來 買在這邊啦
真的很扯 台灣50耶
你問我一次說
我也沒想過 什麼意思
我從來沒有想過說
等一下喔 放大
我從來沒想到我現在這邊
台灣50漲的比國巨還快
可是你去看 有新聞出來
來 我跟你講
全台灣唯一法院 證交所證明
絕不跟主力掛鉤的分析師
有新聞出來
這是中國的
中國的那個好像中央社報導
央視財經報導
AI需求不墜
連大陸的MLCC都接單旺
有沒有看到
風華高科有沒有看到
風華高科
聽起來好像瘋狂高歌 離去
銷量 這占比的銷量
銷量跟銷售額都倍增
除以這個銷售額 好不好
這營收淨利有沒有
核心廠三環
這個沒有聽過
風華高科總有聽過吧 好不好
都沒聽過沒關係
大陸的MLCC的廠商有沒有
AI算力升級
單機MLCC用量兩到三倍
有沒有看到
還有光模組需求也需要
500到1000顆
採購週期3到6個月有沒有看到
我做圖都很OK 有沒有看到
這是大陸的有沒有看到 好不好
還有這個擴產
都擴產到很誇張有沒有看到
所以大陸真的MLCC缺
那只有大陸缺嗎
全世界不會缺嗎 一樣嘛
那我再問你一件事
1200的國巨
跟現在的國巨
我跟你講 這個是意外
就是國巨居然漲那麼多
所以有時候真的很難預測
可是我可以告訴你
國巨真的發動的時候
800塊很快
再講一次
國巨真的發動的時候800塊很快
你們不要覺得不可能
應該現在那個
每個禮拜五有公布股東人數
助理幫我看一下股東人數
做個圖表
那個國巨的股東人數應該下滑了 來
其實我是習慣了
我已經用這個永豐的20年了
用這個軟體用20年了
從頭到尾都沒改變
不然其實我覺得XQ比較好用
我是希望永豐的
軟體要改一下
趁賺錢的時候
不然行情不好會很慘
這個軟體真的不太行
穩定度不太行
扯遠了 我不要變成攻擊人家
來 就是一般軟體XQ
可以直接查券商的那個
有些軟體可以查那個
那個法人的進出
法人進出就算了
這邊可以直接查1000張以下的
800張 幾張以下的大戶數量
扯遠了
沒關係 我叫助理做一下
一樣 華新科300元以下
連300以下都是買點
真的要噴了
剛才說哲哲 你不理鴻海了 放生了
我沒有放生
他只是沒動
我再講一次
這個大盤是這樣漲
現在只漲拉積盤 對不對
看一下大盤
這是大盤對不對
這是我買的這一天對不對
看一下上櫃
有沒有看到
上櫃這樣不準
看起來他漲很多
這樣看好了 沒錯吧
這樣是不是很明顯 再看一下
是不是高點 有沒有看到
大盤在這邊
上櫃在這邊
大盤這邊 上櫃在這邊
來看一次大盤
有沒有看到 在這邊
大盤在這邊 上櫃在這邊
這個價差就是你的獲利空間
這個價差就是你潛在獲利空間
我一定要一直強調
好不好 一直強調
你要記得我這件事
我都敢跟你講一個月內了
我跟你講
當然不能說百分之百
但是我覺得機率很高 好不好
國巨員工待遇好嗎 不太好
川湖的待遇也很差
還不是賺很多錢
乖乖更慘 是不是
乖乖不是什麼工作20年35000
我們這邊一堆員工
一個月賺的錢
可能就是他們一輩子賺的錢
這個沒辦法 我們就是待遇好
20年賺的錢 有可能啦
有些人真的很誇張
現在行情真的很好
你自己算 好不好
所以我們就是敢給 好不好
蠻多摩爾分析師說會到5萬點
我們大家英雄所見略同
我講的是39000的時候
39000的時候誰講
我不要講多
講多變成我批評我們摩爾分析師
我連同業都不指名道姓批評
更何況摩爾
摩爾是品質保證
真的有差啦 你們相信我說的啦
低的時候誰敢講 來
精材要噴了嗎
0050很強
環球晶加碼200股
來 我們看一下大家有沒有什麼
按讚 現在幾分
430 你看每天都要強迫你們這樣按讚
按一下讚
不按讚呢 不好意思 好不好
10分鐘內結束 好不好
趕快按讚
今天很聰明喔
2000個讚 好不好
我們直播人數5000多
2000人也還好吧
還有3000人沒按讚 好不好
沒有就算了喔 好不好
國巨員工待遇比摩爾待遇少得多
對啦 謝謝啦 我們待遇真的不錯
死抱哲哲股 你們會賺翻
前幾天不是還有人講嗎
跟我三期而已
賺了幾千萬 好不好
你看連台灣50都拉起來
所以股票是不是等的 等啦
而且那個等也沒等很久
你們冷靜一下 今年台灣股市漲60%了
60%很扯耶
以前台灣50 是不是
你漲十幾%而已耶 13%而已耶
一年勝過五年了
在2020年之前
台灣50平均成長率
包含台積電
13%以內 甚至10%以內
現在是漲60%耶
一年勝過五年還不夠喔
所以休息一下
台灣股市今天那麼強
已經很變態了 你懂不懂
天啊 各位寶貝們 是不是
最強是台灣50啊
你看台積電還有一段距離
25 35
也差不多
可是台積電看起來沒動對不對
可是你買0050
這一波你買0050就賺翻了
0050看起來就很明顯喔 對不對
0050看起來很明顯喔
再看一次 這是0050
台積電
變化不多喔 雖然都很像
但是0050這一波強翻了
你看喔 台積電還沒突破這個前高
0050先突破這個前高
2000萬
是不是 好不好
來 是不是很多人討厭國巨
不是 因為很多人受過傷了 好不好
哲哲這麼佛心 免費的讚不按
免費的讚你不按
以後就要按有錢的讚
不是友情的讚 是要付錢的讚
你說週一會大漲500點
真的大漲500點
恭喜你可以當分析師
有本事要留名字 考分析師
告訴大家每天的點數
很難啦
我剛才客人都說他買的都套住
你要看哲哲分析師
連台灣50都上去 精材怎麼上不去
神經病喔 精材我們賺很多耶
你看 你們看很短
真的是 來
精材這樣哪叫上不去
看不出來隨時要噴
你也拜託一下
從這邊288漲到496
跌到443很強啦
知不知道 不要開玩笑好不好
來 我們看一下我們今天有些股票
然後群聯
慢慢拉起來好不好
那我們看一下3035
這個我覺得最近智原怪怪的
特別強
去看一下有沒有接到訂單
這種股票是轉機股
就是基本面現在很爛
你不要看191塊
基本面還算爛的
一轉機 ASIC
有人叫他們做這種特製的AI晶片
那不得了啦
那時候就是變本夢比
那時候要先卡位
所以我們先卡位一點點
什麼時候 很難講
技術線型有時候告訴你
如果應該 如果到時候股價
基本上如果股價
輕輕鬆鬆突破220
因為這種行情不應該一次突破
他收到訂單他會漲很快
我再講一次
他如果拿到新的訂單他會漲很快
220會一下突破
220在這邊
他會一下突破
那這邊 就算這邊追都還來得及
好不好
那他就會3 400以上
400元以上好不好
很多股票真的要噴出去啦
好 我看一下還有什麼股票
趕快按讚喔 再看一下
時間不多囉
不然我要提早結束也好 輕輕鬆鬆
反正我提早結束喔 我會員還是很多
可是我跟你講
現在直播的人就變少
之前一萬多人
你們真的是
一定要我每天脫衣服才會看我嗎
好不好 來
台虹 緯穎 你們很奇怪
你們的股票來找我
如果是我的會員
我一定把你手邊的持股
來個持股診斷
再講一次
如果你是我手邊的會員喔
我一定會把你的持股給你診斷
夜盤也噴了 夜盤為什麼噴了
我跟你講是不是那個要和談了
81點還好啦
可是我告訴你 我再講一次喔
我講十次都可以
你一定會覺得
你知道為什麼我郭哲榮
能成為188%男人嗎
因為我的預測能力太強了
那個選股對我來說是最簡單的
選股冠軍說老實話
你每次都選股 你就有機會冠軍了
可是選股冠軍紀錄保持者只有一個 我
為什麼 為什麼每次參加比賽
都是能當選股紀錄保持者
比周杰倫去參加金曲獎
然後得到最佳歌手的次數
感覺還特別多
我每次都選股紀錄保持者
為什麼 我不只要當分析師
我要當預言家
我在講一件事
一個月內美伊就會和談有個結果
石油價格就會大幅下滑
Wait and see
我什麼時候跟你這樣用力拍成這樣子
很久沒拍了 我跟你講
而且是預告的時候拍
每次都是臭屁完
對的時候才拍
我沒有 在預告的時候拍 我告訴你
你會發現我很變態 來自未來
一個月內 相信我 甚至更快
所以你趕快把握
你有閒錢趕快壓 趕快All in
到時候我的名言
叫你All in就All in
叫你重壓就重壓
來 今天這個已經講到第五次了吧
今天這個節目第五次
就是美伊和談一個月內
今天是9月21號
到時候原油價格大幅度下滑
我跟你講 我是很有信心
你現在如果有開個賭局的話
我不知道分析師可不可以賭這個
但是我也沒興趣
可是開個賭局的話 合法的話
如果我賭合法的話
我跟你講 我認為9成的勝率
美伊會在一個月內和談
可以拍個節拍嗎
不好意思 我節奏感還好
如果唱歌又好聽 又會跳舞
那你們不是愛上我
然後重訓又OK
昨天重訓好累 你知道嗎
我昨天重訓 重訓到十點多
有沒有長肌肉 練肩膀
這個嘴巴好像變香腸嘴
好啦 就這樣
可以預定月餅禮盒
蘋果摺疊機會如何
那個就不是AI 能怎麼辦
哲哲知道我賺最多
你是我的會員嗎 賺多少
覺得被動元件洗多久
我真的不知道
我說老實話 我覺得早就該噴了
我沒有想過台灣股市
已經先上48000
然後國巨還在600元以下
還甜甜價 是不是
哲哲我每天都乖乖按讚
可不可以幫我看光聖有沒有戲
為什麼要看光聖有沒有戲
對喔 我看期貨最後拉起來是不是
你看現在期貨價差
你看期貨最後拉起來
你們看一下這個走勢就知道
很誇張耶
這個是大盤期貨 最後又拉起來了
期貨尾盤又拉了
所以你看喔 期貨已經48125
我們看一下期貨喔
我們看一下期貨日線圖
很恐怖耶 來 我們看一下
所以大盤大概剩500點嘛 對不對
你們要搞清楚喔
期貨只剩下多少
大概110點而已耶
你看喔 現在42130喔
有沒有 這邊42130
現在 對不起
現在48000了
48130點了 期指喔
在這邊
這邊最高點 就是最高點這邊
多少 49240有沒有看到
我給它重複一下 49240
49240 我看錯了喔
之前期貨怎麼這麼高啊
夜盤啦 夜盤啦
對不起 我要修正我的話
我本來以為48240
期貨那時候好高喔
可是期貨 好 那我們先
這一段我先不要理它
可是期貨48130
記起來喔 現在點數喔
來喔 來喔 來喔
有沒有看到
是不是很靠近48218
以前好瘋狂喔 正價差1000點喔
可能應該是晚上夜盤
有沒有看到 再看一下
還真的咧
現在已經
期貨已經48100多點了喔 放大
之前現貨48218 OK嗎
如果大盤跟期貨都來到48000
那不好意思 就更近了喔
現在正價差你看一下
高達多少
又來到400點
47700 400點
正價差有沒有看到 這兩個正價差
差400點 期貨又多400點
很誇張的一個數字喔 好不好
這個跟大家講
身材練好穿什麼衣服都好看 謝謝大家
期貨軋空我賺最多
我記得以前投顧老師還會丟筆
對 沒錯 張國治
但是我應該現在比他紅
不好意思 因為看成交量就知道
而且我轉眼間當分析師20年了
OK 來
這沒關係啦 來
每個時代都有每個時代紅的分析師
重點是能不能賺到錢
紅不紅也不是重點
我很紅沒讓你賺到錢也沒意義
懂不懂 OK
你是不是小叮噹
先等到時候
台灣股市就是因為這件事
突破48000
甚至突破50000點
然後美伊也和談了
然後突破這個歷史新高
你再稱讚我好不好
說我是不是小叮噹好不好
今天的量是不是不夠大
你講的是我的重訓量嗎 還是成交量
沒有啦 開玩笑
男生太壯也不好
哲哲你長得好帥 謝謝你
怎麼都是男生表白
不過哲哲年輕的時候
好像年輕的時候沒什麼女人緣
你們不敢相信
就是喜歡我的男生
比喜歡我的女生多
是真的 來
女生緣也有啦
扯遠了 幹嘛講這個 不重要
哲哲私人的事情不重要
股票賺錢就好
投資品德比較重要
哲哲兒 台勝科 我是你兒子
好啦 看一下3532台勝科
台勝科沒什麼啦
矽晶圓都有機會拉起來
這都是一樣
台灣一堆股票噴出去
我跟你講 相信我
我還是要強調一件事 來
到時候我再拿這句話跟大家講
來看一下
大盤快創新高了
櫃買還差一大截
這就是你的獲利空間
大盤快創新高了
櫃買還差一大截
這就是你的獲利空間
我的股票是先求不傷身 再求療效
那我要講的是說
加這個LINE對不對
@s178
Threads都很多假的
Threads每次都說什麼
什麼另外一個哲哲不行了
哲哲賠5000萬了
現在都用假帳號
然後都會打藍勾勾
那都胡扯的
圖片裡面的藍勾勾絕對是假的
是要帳號旁邊
我帳號旁邊的藍勾勾被人家檢舉了
沒關係 以我講的為主
什麼意思
YouTube是全台灣最合法的
因為YouTube會打詐騙
臉書 Threads IG
是同一個集團
他們都不打詐騙的 OK嗎
來 看一下
那你不相信沒關係
LINE已經幫我們打詐騙了
哲哲怎麼看
這邊有藍盾牌白勾勾
詐騙集團絕對不會有這個
叫你主動加LINE的
很多都是騙你的 絕對不會有勾勾
不相信 再點照片
照片直接講 已認證三個字
還是有白勾勾
他們頂多在這邊P圖啦
不可能在這邊
因為只要圖片都可以造假
再講一次 只要圖片都可以造假
可是在這邊對話框裡面點照片
會出現已認證
詐騙集團做不了壞事
這邊會有白勾勾
沒有就是騙你的
就這麼簡單 好不好
OK 沒有就是騙你的好不好
每天要稍微跟大家講
國巨股東夭壽
難怪拉不起來
都不知道是不是我太紅了
國巨股東又增加了啦
股東人數增加了 夭壽喔
54萬變62萬啦
還有得磨啦 沒有關係啦
看有沒有上去的時候把它磨掉
好不好
你看喔 這次空單很特別喔
從8萬多口
有沒有2000個按讚
沒有2000個按讚
我現在結束了喔 是不是
還剩1分鐘 下好離手
沒有我要結束了喔 趕快按讚
不要按兩下 按兩下就沒了喔
來 本來8萬多口空單有沒有看到
一路減有沒有 結算見轉折有沒有
結算前一天還有83000
結算當天76000
從83000口變成現在74000口
助理那個柱狀體可以再長一點嗎
83000變成74000
減了快9000口
減了9000多口空單
就是換句話說增加9000多口多單
減了9000口的空單
難怪要做多嘛 是不是
這都跟大家講
哲哲也是全台灣少數
有期貨分析師牌照的喔
好不好 你們家有沒有
要選就選最紅的
你們家有沒有
來 我們看一下
環球晶隨時要噴
哲哲怎麼看華邦電
要死不活到時候都有機會噴啦
相信我 好不好
因為現在很多大戶 中實戶
覺得5萬點
台灣股市今天漲這麼多 不拉了
不拉沒關係
反正台灣股市會拉到10萬點
他不拉 有別的大戶要拉 OK嗎
好不好 拉不拉多
不拉 我找拉不拉多來拉
冷笑話 對不起
來 我們看一下
真的以後我可能不直播了
因為我覺得色彩
我想要畫面漂亮一點
看一下 叮咚
哲哲說話算話 來
看一下剩幾個
你們夭壽 一定要這麼刺激嗎
你們真的以為我不會關掉
我還真的會關掉 我是跟你說真的
按多一點讚啦
另外4000人呢 在幹什麼
不要一直吃哲哲豆腐
哲哲聯發科打算賺多少
先50%吧 好不好
先6000塊好不好 6000多
那時候買多少錢
我們來看一下聯發科的恭賀簡訊
我們現在才賺14%而已 OK嗎
倒推一下算我的成本就知道
對你不錯吧
目前 好不好
因為這是會員資訊啊
怎麼覺得我今天沒置中是不是
遮住了
是本來就有遮住這一點點是不是
來 我們來請美女念個圖一下
念個這個簡訊
好 9月21日禮拜一 今天的簡訊
特Call簡訊
恭喜2454聯發科
股價大漲突破5000元
再創歷史新高
我們買進後 最高已經獲利14%
我持續看好它 手上持股獲利續抱
恭喜大家賺大錢啦
我是全台灣第一個講結算見轉折的分析師
我再講一次 我是全台灣第一個
我沒騙你
我可以找以前的紀錄來跟你講
那你看為什麼
那現在很多人模仿我 我不在乎
那為什麼剛好就結算見轉折
這邊就是
有沒有看到 這邊結算日
再漲2000多點
45000再漲2000多點
你告訴我哪個分析師
能像我這樣預告未來
第二個 我現在再給你另外一個預告
我說這個伊朗和談 我再講一次
你不要覺得這不重要
你不要覺得我重複
因為有些人 哲哲你不要講了
我不管你 來
這一次伊朗的條件有沒有看到
4月提的很多 這次都沒提了
這一次提的 9月提的東西對不對
大幅減少要求
而且都是可以行的
你不能談了協議 伊朗要掌控海峽
那川普能答應嗎 現在沒有
他說履行條件就重開海峽
沒有說到底誰掌控誰
有沒有看到
你不能說你要叫美軍撤出區域 怎麼可能
你變成中東霸主
川普死都不可能答應
現在要求解除海上封鎖
未提全面撤軍
他沒有要提撤軍
這沒提撤軍 OK
所以代表伊朗縮了
嘴巴很硬 身體很誠實
各位男生你要追女生呢 也是一樣
女生說喜不喜歡你
你不用問了 直接約一下就知道了
好不好 OK嗎
行動代表一切 這樣懂不懂
有些女生 你覺得這個男生愛不愛你
嘴巴說愛你 怎麼會是渣男呢
說對我很好 怎麼不付錢呢
就是不愛你
就這麼簡單 就是不夠愛你
這沒辦法 事實啦
每個人想法 AA制
是啦 可是夠愛你就會多出一點點錢
是不是 好不好
不要一定要AA
好像韓國 日本有討論過
說大概男女比大概7比3
覺得這比較合理
也是啦 因為像日本 韓國也是
男生的薪水比較高
可是條件更好的男生
願意出更多的錢
所以你要找到好的女生要得出錢
這個扯遠了
女生不要想說男生到底愛不愛你
願意付出 懂不懂
所以願意付出 OK嗎
所以嘴巴怎麼說不重要
行為表示
伊朗這次看起來就要停戰了
扯遠了 都可以扯到
戰爭都可以扯到愛情 扯到股市
美中AI競賽 好不好
這一定會AI競賽 還要成立AI部隊
是不是 AI沙皇是不是
他不要撒謊就好了
川普啦
AI商業化
大模型的ARR的差距
好不好 就是這個
投報的ARR限制 好不好 OK
任命AI沙皇 好不好
成立人工智慧部隊
不增設新防護規範 協助發展
不增設規範 看起來就要做真的
我那時候不是跟你講一件事嗎
來 請你告訴我
網路泡沫
政府說竭盡我所能要發展網路嗎
有說不發展網路死定了嗎
沒有啊
我告訴你 我說過了
現在是AI時代
為什麼是AI時代
以後啊 第一個台灣人口減少
如果兩岸發生戰爭
都不是台灣人在打啦
台灣人可能台灣人在打
中國可能不只人海戰術
先用機器人
機器人 機器狗
你看那個機器人可以上春晚了
以後可不可以打仗 當然可以啊
登陸找他登陸啊
沒差 我遠端控制就好了啊
對不對 我1萬台機器人不夠
我發明100萬台可不可以
大陸做得到啊 為什麼不行
人機戰術就把台灣搞垮了
我要告訴大家未來趨勢就是這樣子
你看烏克蘭跟俄羅斯是無人機的戰爭
接下來是機器人戰爭
我本來不相信
記不記得我去年的時候
我還說機器人不會那麼快
可是我現在看到轉折我發現有可能
AGI來了
就是通用人工智慧
可以從無到有 還可以自己學習
重點是來了
很多人說AI不會變現
AI不會投資 因為它沒報酬
第一個AI進步那麼快
他們憑什麼講
第二個我是不是一直講
就算廠商不投資
政府也會投資啊
有沒有看到 政府也會投資啊
所以美中AI競賽升溫
有沒有看到 還不設立規範
所以你們在想什麼 10萬點
3年10萬點我是送分題
所以我都規劃好了
為什麼我不要今年5萬點
我1億台灣50
大概就賺2500萬
為什麼我不要捐救護車
2500萬捐一台救護車
也勉強可以啦 為什麼
500萬 救護車很貴500萬喔
不是什麼看護巴士
什麼一般的車子 是500萬
2500萬捐一台救護車可以 為什麼
問題是太快了 我想一年捐一台
我還很年輕
我想捐個23縣市 22縣市
至少大概20
不一定要每個縣市
就是差不多啦 就是輪流捐啦
可是就是想要捐個22台 23台
所以明年就可以捐啦
明年什麼時候
明年就大概6萬點
所以我告訴你
我順便預測行情
明年6萬點捐
那時候就賺5000萬
捐一台不是很好 對不對
希望大家真的
除了攻擊哲哲 很多同業攻擊哲哲
你也可以捐款啦
哲哲錢比較多
你也可以在股市中賺錢啊
是不是歪理 他們是不是歪理
聯電 力積電醞釀大漲價
有沒有看到
成熟製程大爆發
那我的5347世界先進怎麼不行
你告訴我為什麼不會噴出去
我就說5347世界先進
看起來要噴出去啦
來真的啦 這種走勢
就像智原看起來
有一點點要有感覺
有沒有看到 一點點
智原還好
可是這個5347世界先進
基本面更好 好不好
今天還是差不多提早結束啦
因為我沒有到很滿意
但是沒有很早 好不好
全台唯一嫌錢賺太多
對啊 我沒有一定要賺很多
你們要不要參加會員
我跟你講 每次公司的副總
總經理都說
哲哲 你幹嘛說要不要參加隨便他們
我說不然咧
你們要不要參加隨便你啊
我沒有缺會員
這樣講很討厭 真的沒有啊
反正已經很多人參加了
我還要拜託你 那實在是
這個不叫第一名分析師啊
要不要參加隨便你
所以你們要覺得我嫌錢賺太多也可以
我沒有
我只是有時候
我賺到錢我要捐出去
幫大家一起做善事
這樣子 OK嗎 好不好
哲哲中秋節會烤肉嗎
可能出去一下
這個跟大家講
環球晶的GDR會影響股價嗎
會 可是定價完畢以後就不會了
上次就沒有了
OK嗎 OK 來
現在找不到開救護車的司機
捐點別的
這個邏輯很奇怪
救護車司機一定是有缺額
救護車一定有缺額我才捐
不是我想捐就可以捐 OK
來 助理有一個叫陳永誠 有嗎
摩爾哲哲的助理中有一個叫陳永誠
印象中沒有
所以你看很多網路上
也有可能直接講
我們同名同姓的助理
這不是重點
我的重點就是你要記得
你不知道的話你就加我的LINE
LINE裡面上面有
有藍盾牌白勾勾
最上面沒有藍盾牌白勾勾
絕對是假的
你不要看照片裡面的
是點完照片以後
旁邊有寫已認證 好不好
這就沒辦法造假 聽得懂嗎
只要是照片都有可能造假
OK嗎
這樣懂我的邏輯嗎
還不懂邏輯
那你不要參加會員好了
真的 我怕你被騙
這個很簡單
應該沒有這個人
好啦 就這樣子
我不要 這個我講過很多次
我不要每天
每天都要跟你們講防詐騙
這樣花太多時間也沒意義
哲哲後面頭髮有抓嗎
後面頭髮沒有抓
有壓一下 有時候亂翹
我的頭髮很翹
我不抓也大概這個髮型
好不好 要結束了
來 中秋大拍賣
所以差不多要結束了
今天還有什麼股票 趕快來
我的股票還沒講的
你不要一直問你的股票 各位
技嘉啦 在這裡啦
技嘉有沒有
技嘉看起來要噴了喔
技嘉在這裡好不好
技嘉 在這裡 放大
在這裡
那最後跟大家講簡訊 你看
今天聯發科賺14%有沒有看到
世界先進
恭喜5347的世界先進
世界先進股價已經連4紅
再平2個月新高
我們多次買進 最高獲利18%
我們成本也有高的
我持續看好它 手上持股抱好抱牢
你去想想看你要怎麼樣的分析師
好不好
這個都預告在前面 好不好
這些股票都OK
什麼記憶體
記憶體不用擔心
很多人說
宏碁的老闆說記憶體不行
不要開玩笑 他去年就說不行了
先把宏碁拉起來吧
我就覺得一個老闆
去執著於這個要幹嘛
如果你錯了 人家不會覺得丟臉嗎
我真的勸他
本來還不覺得他很傻
宏碁的老闆
不要再一直唱衰記憶體了
趨勢是沒辦法改變的
你會讓人家覺得你不懂AI
真的 這樣我變成批評他
但是我講的是事實
不要一直唱衰
你又不是分析師
你幹嘛扛這個責任 對不對
預測對了 你很厲害嗎
公司把他營收搞起來
預測錯了人家講你不懂AI
你這個宏碁的老闆不懂AI 對不對
幹嘛去唱衰這個記憶體
而且沒有理由
真的你唱衰記憶體
代表你根本
我說老實話
如果你這個人唱衰記憶體
代表你根本不懂AI進展多快
那你要被下一個時代
所以如果宏碁的老闆還是這個想法
我近期 我這一年都不會買宏碁的股票
代表不懂AI的人會被淘汰
我這樣講好像批評他
我是講事實 好不好
所以哲哲都預期在前面好不好
宏碁跟佳世達一樣
哪時候選股比賽
我又讓給別人了
因為我現在太紅了 不需要了
來 我1億0050賺2000萬
這件事讓台股上5萬
就是至少這件事
會讓台灣股市突破歷史新高
48000多以上
就是美伊和談
在一個月內 好不好
看一下 拉遠
2026年9月21號
在這邊我預告
一個月內美伊和談
10月底之前原油價格會大幅度下滑
你到時候就知道就簽和談
很確定的簽和談 OK嗎
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
很多股票
我台灣50轉眼間 我賺了2000萬
1987萬 在這邊買進
放大喔 這邊買進
厲害嗎 放到現在還在抱
賺了2000萬了
我還要賺更多
我還要賺到5000萬再捐一台救護車
回饋社會
因為有你們讓我有動力回饋社會
也希望你們跟我一起賺大錢
也希望你們怎麼樣
在這一波行情
發現好像賺錢並不難
接下來會是很多中小型個股
很多矽晶圓 被動元件 記憶體
很多趴在地上的股票
會不知不覺噴出去
不論對或錯哲哲一切的一切預告在前面
歡迎來電洽詢0800668085
或者加我的LINE私訊我說
哲哲 怎麼參加會員
哲哲 我手邊有股票
沒問題你參加會員 我會幫你解決
哲哲 怎麼樣 會費多少
我竭盡所能來幫你賺大錢
謝謝各位 Byebye